si le machine learning n'est autre que
de l'apprentissage ne s'agit-il pas d'un
simple problème de mémorisation
par exemple pour programmer syrie ou au
quai google ne pourrait-on pas faire
retenir des dialogues à unir pour
qu'elle connaisse les réponses
classiques aux questions usuelles unis à
ayant mémorisé beaucoup de savoir ne
serait-elle pas intelligente vous voyez
le problème on en a déjà parlé dans
l'épisode 3 le nombre de discussions
imaginables est beaucoup plus grand que
le nombre de particules dans l'univers
est donc clairement un ordinateur ne
peut pas mémoriser toutes ces
discussions ne serait ce parce que la
quasi-totalité des discussions
imaginables ont non seulement jamais eu
lieu
elles n'ont même jamais été écrites et
c'est un petit peu dur de mémoriser des
données qui n'ont jamais été produite
mais beaucoup de discussions se
ressemblent je vous dis rentrer ça va et
comment ça va c'est un peu du pareil au
même
d'où l'idée de faire de l'interpolation
père de l'interpolation c'est dire que
si je n'ai jamais vu la phrase comment
ça va mais si j'ai vu passer les
questions ça va comment tu vas comment
ça roule alors les réponses à ces
questions surtout si ce sont les mêmes
sont sans doute des bonne réponse à la
question initiale
bon là je vous ai donné la version test
de turing de l'interpolation mais les
applications de l'interpolation sont
très nombreuses dans tous les domaines
imaginables en sciences en entreprise ou
pour choisir le prochain film que vous
allez voir au cinéma
imaginons que vous veniez de voir la
fiche du film pentagone papers vous vous
dites que ça doit être vachement cool
parce que ça a l'air de pareilles de
cette étrange figure géométrique et le
pentagone mais vous hésitez parce que il
n'ya pas de frein taiwan sur la fiche du
coup vous en parler un ami qui vient de
le voir et de façon cruciale qui
partagent les mêmes goûts
cinématographiques que vous il a aimé le
film vous devinez que vous allez aimer
le film vous aussi et si la détestez
vous devinez que vous allez le détestez
vous aussi félicitations vous venez
d'appliquer un algorithme de machine
learning qu'on appelle l'algorithme du
plus proche voisin uni rust never en
anglais pour faire une prédiction y pour
un individu x cet algorithme du plus
proche voisin va chercher l'individu
exprime le plus similaire à x dont il
connaît la valeur de y prime ici bien
sûr exprime c'est votre ami
cinématographique mon proche y prime est
la vie de votre ami et la prédiction y
que vous allez faire est calculé via
l'équation y est égal à y prime ça va
tout le monde suit alors dans le langage
usuel du machine learning les x sont
appelés des caractéristiques ou fitch 2
et les y sont appelés des étiquettes ou
les boys je m'excuse auprès des
défenseurs de la langue française
mais je vais utiliser la terminologie
anglaise parce que c'est celle qui est
utilisée au niveau de la recherche et
puis il a fait aussi deux fois moins
deux syllabes et enfin et surtout je
fais mon politiciens démagogues qui ne
fait que suivre l'opinion publique sur
twitter le problème du machine learning
donc c'est souvent présenté comme la
prédiction de les buzz à partir des
faiseuses d'une donnée en fait plus
précisément c'est ce que l'on appelle
l'apprentissage superviser ou sup vice
teneur ning en anglais les applications
de l'apprentissage superviser sont très
nombreuses en sciences ont santé ou sur
internet le problème de l'apprentissage
superviser c'est de construire une
fonction de prédiction c'est à dire une
fonction qui prend des fishers et qui
calcule des levels qui correspondent à
ses futures et pour construire cette
fonction l'apprentissage superviser va
s'appuyer sur un ensemble de perdre fit
choses et les boys
retenez bien tout ça on va beaucoup
travailler avec ce formalisme dans les
vidéos à venir dans cela l'algorithme du
plus proche voisin et bien une solution
au problème de l'apprentissage
superviser il repose d'abord sur la
mémorisation de tous les exemples puis
pour effectuer une prédiction pour des
futurs x l'algorithme va calculer f 2 x
est égal à y prime ou y primé le les
bols de plus proche voisin exprime 2x en
mémoire et ce qui est vraiment bien avec
cet algorithme
c'est quelqu'un de super simple mais
j'imagine que vous sentez venir le
problème
même votre ami qui vous est le plus
semblable n'est pas toujours d'accord
avec vous parfois il raconte même des
trucs à bitumer un truc marrant hier
j'ai renversé deux cyclistes
voilà une millions d'instinct en sang
pour être moins susceptibles aux erreurs
de votre ami une variante de
l'algorithme du plus proche voisin
consiste à son d'évoca amis les plus
proches cinématographiquement et ensuite
combiné leurs avis pour estimer vos
chance d'aimer le film c'est ce que l'on
appelle l'algorithme des cas plus
proches voisins ou kanye west amber ou
encore k n est qu à nn ou des variantes
de cayenne c'est un algorithme et de
machine learning souvent utilisé en
pratique notamment par les géants du web
qui peuvent chercher vos semblables au
delà de vos cercles d'amis sauf que la
recherche que jean semblables sur le web
pose maintenant un autre problème à
savoir le calcul de la similarité entre
des individus
pour calculer la similarité entre deux
profils facebook facebook peut utiliser
toutes les données entrées par les
utilisateurs
mais faisons simple pour commencer
supposons que facebook ne considère que
l'âge de la personne et le nombre de ses
amis facebook
autrement dit on va supposer que les
phishers d'un individu sont de nombre x
âge et x amis on peut alors représenter
graphiquement la personne en question
comme étant un point d'un espace dans
les axes sont de l'âge et le nombre
d'amis l'espace des phisheurs est alors
un plan de dimension 2 intuitivement on
va supposer que les individus avec des
âges et des nombres d'amis facebook
semblables ont des goûts
cinématographiques plus semblable
autrement dit on va supposer que les
individus proches en l'espace d fishers
sont aussi proches cinématographiquement
on a tout ce qu'il faut pour appliquer
qu à nn pour commencer il nous faut une
phase d'apprentissage qui dans le cas de
knn n'est qu'une simple mémorisation
plus spécifiquement vous allez chercher
des lives
c'est à dire une liste de like dislike
et du film pour chaque live good is like
vous regardez le profil de l'individu et
en fonction de son âge et de son nombre
d'amis vous allez situer son light et
dans le graphe fait cela pour tous
pleins d'individus et vous obtenez alors
une carte des les boys dans l'espace
défectueuse on a terminé l'apprentissage
on peut passer aux prédictions pour
prédire si un individu va aimer un film
on va chercher ses features les placer
dans le craf puis on va chercher les
futurs les plus proches en mémoire est
typiquement si le futur est entouré de
like on va prédire que l'individu va
aimer le film
sinon s'il est entouré de quelques laïcs
et beaucoup de dislike on va prédire
qu'il est plutôt probable qu'ils
n'aimera pas le film bref quesnel est un
algorithme de machine learning
incroyablement simple et dont
l'apprentissage est uniquement une
simple mémorisation des données et la a
vu le titre de cette vidéo est tout ce
que vous avez entendu à propos des
réseaux de neurones ou du dip learning
vous vous dites sans doute qu'il y a un
truc qui va clocher avec klm et pourtant
il existe un théorème qui dit que knn
permet toujours de très bien à prendre
ce théorème et le théorème de cover art
en 1967 il affirme que klm finira par
faire quasiment autant d'erreurs qu'une
prédiction optimale oui parce qu'une
prédiction parfaite des préférences
cinématographique d'un individu à partir
uniquement de son âge et de son nombre
d'amis facebook
vous l'imaginez c'est en général
impossible même une prédiction optimale
se trompera une fraction air du temps et
bien qu'elle ne se trompera jamais plus
d'une fraction deux fois air du temps
quand verra-t-on même prouvé une
meilleure bande qui dépend aussi d'une
ombrelle de catégorie que l'on considère
oui parce qu'au lieu d'avoir juste
j'aime j'aime pas on aura aussi pu avoir
bien moyen bof on voit que si la
prédiction optimale se trompe très peu
alors knn se trompera très peu lui aussi
et ça ça semble pas mal résoudre le
problème de l'apprentissage superviser
qu'en pensez vous bien sûr la réponse
est non parce que sinon on n'aurait pas
besoin de diplôme ning mais où est le
problème d'après vous en fait il y en a
trois trois problèmes de complexité les
deux premiers sont des problèmes de
complexité algorithmique
quand on a plusieurs téraoctets de
données la mémorisation des données par
cannes n va faire un fichier de
plusieurs téraoctets ça c'est pas très
pratique déjà ça tire pas sur un
téléphone on dit que quesnel et non
paramétriques parce qu'il grossit avec
la taille des données et pour certaines
applications comme par exemple au lhc ou
des pétaoctets de données sont
collectées à chaque instant c'est juste
pas jouable et l'autre problème du coup
c'est que ça va aussi faire de longs
calculs typiquement sont un des
téraoctets effectuer une prédiction peut
prendre des minutes de calcul mais
surtout le troisième et le plus
important problème c'est la complexité
d'échantillonnage
c'est à dire le nombre de données
nécessaires pour effectuer un bon
apprentissage
c'est vraiment là que le bât blesse et
pour comprendre pourquoi il va nous
falloir parler de la dimension de
l'espace des freeters et oui les
bizarreries des espaces de très grandes
dimensions sont en fait indispensable à
comprendre
pour bien comprendre de machine learning
dans notre exemple on a vu un espace des
features deux dimensions de mets en
pratique si vous considérez toutes les
infos d'une page facebook notamment
toutes les pages qui ont été leakée tous
les postes qui ont été leakée ou pire
encore toutes les photos on a rapidement
un espace d fishers deux dimensions 1000
voire un million et oui on a une
nouvelle dimension pour chaque type
d'informations qu'on trouve sur une page
profil facebook
sauf que les espaces de dimensions 1
millions sont en un sens beaucoup plus
passion que espace des dimensions 2 pour
comprendre tout ça on va commencer
simple on va partir de la dimension de
on va prendre
l'objet le plus classique de la
dimension de à savoir le carré un carré
ça à quatre sommets
j'espère que jusque là tout de suite en
dimension 3 1 carré devient récurent et
un cube a maintenant lui sommet en fait
à chaque fois qu'on monte d'une
dimension on double le nombre de sommets
puisque montée d'une dimension revient à
un copier coller le cube et à translate
est l'une des copies à travers la
nouvelle dimension
il vous renvoie vers cette vidéo de
michael sonné pour en savoir plus mais
alors l'hyper cubes de dimension des va
avoir deux puissances des sommets
imaginons pour simplifier que les
phishers soit toujours des sommets de ce
cube alors après avoir collecté deux
puissances dément une donnée vous
n'aurez couvert que la moitié des
sommets de l'hyper cubes ce qui veut
dire que pour la majorité des futurs
imaginables vous n'aurez aucun très
proches voisins sur lequel vous appuyer
pour effectuer une prédiction
autrement dit en gros en dimensions d il
faut environ deux puissances des données
pour que ken fonctionne sauf qu'en
pratique on l'a vu dès souvent de
l'ordre de 1000 voire un million voire
en fait beaucoup beaucoup plus si l'on
considère par exemple le test de turing
horde est le cas d égale 1000 pour que
quesnel fonctionne il faut deux
puissances mille donné et ça c'est bien
plus grand que le nombre de particules
dans l'univers et c'est pour ça que ken
échoue en apprentissage superviser dès
que le nombre de dimensions de l'espace
défi just n'est pas tout petit alors
tout n'est pas à rejeter pour autant en
pratique cayenne et souvent combinée à
un apprentissage des pictures pertinents
typiquement peut-être une variation de
10 amis facebook n'est pas aussi
pertinent pour la prédiction de
préférence cinématographique une
variation d'âge de 10 ans prendre en
compte ce genre de considérations
revient à changer ce qu'on entend par
proximité ou similarités on parle
d'apprentissage de la métrique de canet
et sa basse et un sacré problème est la
façon qui semble la plus commune pour
apprendre cette métrique tout cas
aujourd'hui
ça semble consister à transformer
l'espace des features via un réseau de
neurones typiquement en transformant
l'espace des symboles syntaxique en un
espace de sémantique on y viendra
mais il va nous falloir pas mal
d'épisodes pour en arriver là l'anr fois
on a parlé de l'argument de turing est
la raison pour laquelle le machine
learning est nécessaire et sans doute
suffisant pour permettre une
intelligence artificielle de niveau
humain l'argument de turing repose
énormément sur la notion de complexité
de kolmogorov et jean michel sarrat vrai
que je parle davantage de cette notion
alors énormément de choses à dire bien
sûr
ça prendra peut-être un petit peu trop
de temps je vais pas le faire
aujourd'hui mais je tiens à signer quand
même que je suis fait taper sur les
doigts par un de mes collègues j'ai
converti au sur le monophysisme et qui
m'a fait remarquer que j'ai appelé sa
complexité de kolmogorov comme tout le
monde
alors qu'en fait c'est sur le mode off
qui a inventé cette complexité et en
plus bien sûr je le sais je n'ai pas
trop osé aller en l'encontre de la
terminologie rétabli mais c'est vrai que
en fait bassée salomé 9 qui a inventé
cette complexité trois ans avant que le
golfe et en plus selon mena fa vraiment
exploiter cette notion pour pouvoir
comprendre ce qu'était l'apprentissage
donc je pense que vraiment sur le mode
off mérite beaucoup plus que kolmogorov
d'être associé à cette notion du coup je
vais appeler ça maintenant la complexité
de solomonoff et je regrette un petit
peu dans la vidéo précédente de pas
l'avoir appelée ainsi non votera
rapidement la complexité de solomonoff
et donc la longueur de la description de
la plus courte solution algorithmique un
problème et on peut utiliser cette
notion de complicité de seulement 9 pour
notamment formaliser la notion de rasoir
d'occam qui nous notions très importante
en épistémologie et en machines en inc
dont on reparlera dans un prochain
épisode
même si la façon classique de parler du
rasoir d'occam en apprentissage
statistiques notamment des pavia la
complexité de somme 9 mai à travers
notre notion qui est à dimension wc on
reparlera de tout ça maxence du ms
demande si j'ai pas un peu traitée de
manière un peu expéditive
l'incompressibilité du cerveau humain
alors oui car mort y aura beaucoup plus
à dire et c'est pas un sujet très facile
particulier emmanuel jacob se demande
pourquoi est-ce-que turing sorti ce
chiffre de 10 puissance 9 qui semble un
peu sortir de nulle part je pense qu'on
est assez d'accord sur ça disait bon
ballon que le cerveau est pas
entièrement incompressibles et qu'en
plus une bonne partie du cerveau qui ne
sont pas indispensables à la résolution
du test de turing et il a eu une
estimation de la taille du cerveau entre
dispense 17 10 puissance 15
aujourd'hui on sait que c'est beaucoup
plus proche de 10 puissance 15 que de
discussions se disent comment le nombre
de synapses et à l'intérieur du cerveau
et du coup on pourrait se dire que
peut-être qu'à partir dispensable du
cerveau pour pouvoir passer le test de
turing est peut-être plus proche de 10
puissance 15 que de différences neuf en
tout cas s'il est plus grand que 10
puissance 9 les arguments de turing
s'applique encore plus unique 20,48 une
demande comment c'est une façon de
prouver qu'un programme est
incompressible ou de calculer parlant de
sa complexité de solomonoff ait baha
pense malheureusement et non en fait là
on nage en plein
de l'indécidabilité c'est à dire qu'il
n'existe pas de façon algorithmique de
déterminer la complexité de solomonoff
d'un problème
et du coup le postulat de turing qui
avait mis en avant dans la vidéo
précédente c'est un problème qui même
s'il était parfaitement définis
mathématiquement on sait aussi qu'il
n'existe aucune façon mathématique de
prouver qu il est vrai plus précisément
il est possible de trouver des bornes
supérieur à la complexité de solomonoff
d'une tâche pour ça il suffit en fait
d'exhiber un algorithme qui résout 7h et
de calculer la longueur de la
description de cet algorithme ce moment
la longueur de la description de cet
algorithme est une borne supérieure mais
on pourra jamais exclure fait qu'il
existe des algorithmes beaucoup plus
courts qui sont capables de résoudre la
tâche aux aussie est la raison pour
laquelle il était impossible de montrer
qu'il n'existe pas de tête zago rythme
c'est parce qu'il ya plein d'algorithmes
assez étrange qui vont faire des calculs
assez bizarre et dont il est impossible
d'anticiper le fait que ses algorithmes
pouvons terminer encore moi qui ont
donné une bonne réponse
et tout ça est lié aux pointes de
l'indécidabilité du poème de l'arrêt
dans les machines à turing c'est aussi
très lié à la complétude de gödel elle
va encore une fois faire la vidéo de
thomas sur patience où il parle
d'incomplétude bref tous ces arguments
ils ne sont pas entièrement convaincant
parce qu'il repose autant sur des
postulats qui sont indémontrable mais ça
n'empêche pas le fait qu'on puisse avoir
une grande confiance en ses postulats
parce que j'ai pas mal confiant son
postulat de turing semble qu'en
directement aujourd'hui on a
l'impression que résoudre au test de
turing sera pas facile avec un
algorithme assez court et qu'il faut
forcément des algorithmes très compliqué
or la seule façon d'explorer les
algorithmes avec des codes sources aussi
lancé via le machine learning et vous
forcément le machine learning est la
clef de l'intelligence artificielle
alors il ya peut-être un petit trou dans
cet argument pointé par jonas daverio
qui est le fait que je suppose qu'il
faille forcément faire du machine
learning pour explorer l'espace des gros
algorithmes crt les codes écrit à la
main ça ça marchera jamais mais je sais
pas en quoi peut-être imaginer comme
l'imaginent laborantins du temps que des
viassois capable un jour des clercs déjà
plus compliqué donc l'exploration des
espaces plus grands pourra peut-être se
faire directement par d'autres et c'est
là que la complexité de ce land of est
un concept très pertinent c'est que si
on a une ia qui est capable d'écrire une
ia avec un code source plus long que
qu'elle même en fait le code source plus
loin il est compréhensible du coup on
fait les la tâche qui est résolu par la
plus grosse
elle est résolue bhl parler à plus petit
suffit en fait de dire lié à plus petit
de résoudre le problème pour ça va
générer le
le plus gros est elle va résoudre le
problème du coût la complexité de
solomonoff de la tâche en question sera
pas celle de lier un plus gros ce sera
celle de l'ia du petit d'une certaine
manière un algorithme seul peut pas
augmenter sa complexité de solomonoff du
coup en cela ils incapables d'explorer
l'espace des algorithmes allons code
source dont le code source est
essentiellement incompressibles alors
techniquement il y reste possible qu'un
petit algorithmes génère un algorithme
plus gros dont la complexité des sols
aux notes soient plus grande que celle
du plq au rythme plus petits si cet
algorithme le plus petit utilise le
hasard pour générer l'algorithme plus
grands en effet ça c'est possible il ya
quand même très peu de chances que cet
algorithme un plus grand s'il est apte
ici la complexité sur le mono fanny
siècle et l'obtient c'est via en fait un
calcul aléatoire résolvent la tâche que
l'on voulait résoudre puisque le nombre
d'algorithmes et qui aurait ainsi pu
être générés par un algorithme plus
court est en fait très très grand et la
plupart sans doute servent à rien en
fait cette idée de gérer l'aléatoire qu
on pourrait rajouter un code source
c'est un problème aussi faire pas mal de
vidéos là dessus c'est notamment cette
notion que capture le concept de
sophistication de se lever 9
si vous chercher ça sur internet vous
avez rien trouvé parce que celle que
j'ai inventé dans un truc qui a pas
encore été publié mais on finira pas en
parler bref l'argument clé c'est qu'on
ne peut pas gagner une complexité
pertinente en partir d'un petit
algorithmes à moins d'utiliser quelque
chose d'autre qui possède déjà une
grande sophistication de solomonoff et
ce truc qui possède déjà cette grande
sophistication de zones off qui peut
aider à guider l'exploration des espaces
d'algorithmes plus grand et forcément
quelque chose qui sera extérieur à
l'algorithme lui-même
du coup sera forcément des données qui
seront du certains mineurs volet de
notre environnement empirique dont la
p6t6 ws est en fait très très grande
donc tout ça c'est des arguments qui
n'était pas vraiment dans turing parce
que ses émotions
je pense que tu ris n'y a pas forcément
tout anticiper on est nous sommes qui
ont été plus anticipé d'ailleurs par
chronographe que parce nov
il y aurait encore énormément à dire
mais l'idée en gros c'est que en gros la
complexité de la ghost me doivent venir
de quelque part
et ce quelque part c'est sans doute le
monde extérieur et notamment les données
empiriques et du coup pour pouvoir créer
un moment une intelligence artificielle
avec une grande complicité de solomonoff
pertinente il faut absolument être
utilisé quelque chose qui vient du monde
extérieur
doux
l'idée d'une machine learning et d'où
l'idée selon laquelle le machine
learning est vraiment un truc
incontournable bref comme le signale
très bien je nassau daverio j'extrapole
pas mal d idées de turing pour essayer
de mieux les clarifier notamment pour le
clarifier c'est utile d'invoquer des
arguments postérieure à turing notamment
ses histoires de sophistication etienne
bertin fait la remarque très pertinente
que le cerveau de l'enfant est très
certainement compressible puisqu'une
certaine manière elle a été
essentiellement générée par le code
génétique de l'enfant
alors bien sûr ces histoires de code
génétique turing ne les connaissais pas
en tout cas pas très bien puisque la dn1
structure d'aden a découvert en 1953 et
son art intel de 1950 notamment le code
génétique humain aujourd'hui on sait
qu'il est composé de 3 milliards de
lettres donc ça se compte en gigaoctets
et commencer que l'adn humain est
capable de créer un cerveau humain
on sait que la complexité de ce lot
menace du cerveau humain bébé est au
plus de quelques gigaoctets
donc ça déjà c'est une très bonne
nouvelle si on dit que c'est moins que
ça en fait a priori la partie de l'adn
qui est vraiment indispensable au codage
de la structure du cerveau humain est
sans doute une petite fraction de tout
l'adn humain et du coup on peut espérer
que le cerveau bébé à une complexité de
solomonoff je sais pas être de l'ordre
du million de l'ibo cote après déjà plus
faisable que camille gare peut-être même
moins pourquoi j'en sais vraiment rien
mais ça me permet comme de rebondir à
nouveau avec l'article de turing qui
proposait de faire une sélection
naturelle des leurs dix machines c'est à
dire des cerveaux enfants la personne
flirter avec l'eugénisme
là je parle bien de la sélection des
learning la chine un des algorithmes de
burning et turing proposé de simuler la
sélection naturelle pour pouvoir
sélectionner les algues au rythme de
machine learning les plus prometteurs
enfin frais nato me fait remarquer que
c'est pas wiktionnaire mais wiktionnaire
dictionnaire wiktionnaire
j'espère que vous avez aimé cette vidéo
donc en train de parler des trucs assez
scolaire jean les désirs de machine
learning apprentissage supervisé qui est
vraiment le truc qui marche très très
bien en fait je pensais que tout le
monde en parle en ce moment donc j'y
suis vraiment pas le machine en ligne
plus général qui soit
la prochaine fois on va continuer dans
cette veine en parlant des algorithmes
et les plus classiques
en fait pour l'apprentissage a supervisé
qui sont des algorithmes très lié à la
structure linéaire des données notamment
la régression minière et la
classification lumière si vous avez
aimez cette vidéo pensez à la ligue et
elle a commenté à la partager pensez à
vous abonner pendant les futurs épisodes
martiaux qui peut encore dont il espère
tirer la quatrième fois la machine
learning
en gros c'est ça on a des données ici
sous la forme d'une entrée x et d'une
sortie grecque
on les présentait un algorithme qui a
des boutons et qu'il est tourner jusqu'à
ce qu'ils aient compris le lien entre x
et y
tu as c'est tout ce qu'on appelle la
phase d'apprentissage et puis une fois
que c'est fait on peut faire des
prédictions que le nombre de sommets de
l'umih percu va être égal au nombre de
sommets du cube de départ plus le nombre
de sommets du cube que l'on va déplacer
vers la na ou le kata et donc lippé
recul va avoir deux fois plus de 100 m
l'écurie va donc avoir seize sommet